hyrule warriors age of calamity features
a rich cast of characters
both old and new we experience most of
the adventure from the vantage point of
the heroes we know and love
established in 2017's breath of the wild
link zelda the champions of the divine
beasts and many more are seen fighting
the good fight against the calamity
which seeks to utterly devastate their
home
despite this you could argue that the
lead role in age of calamity actually
goes
to terraco in a lot of ways this is his
story
a little time traveling guardian who
sets out on a voyage to the past in an
attempt to save zelda her friends
changed the course of history and in the
process creating
and yes for those who are still in
denial about this age of calamity does
indeed utter in a new timeline split for
the series
this is proven from this little excerpt
called splintered worlds
which literally states that as soon as
the guardian traveled back into the past
a new world was born but in this video i
don't want to necessarily talk about the
timeline split itself
but rather about this visitor from
another world since
who or what is terrico exactly
well aside from being one of the cutest
things to ever grace the zelda series
and most likely a distant ancestor of
r2d2
and bb-8 this little guy houses some
extraordinary and powerful abilities
even outclassing the sheikah slate sure
the slate can manipulate time to a small
extent freezing objects in place
but that is still small potatoes
compared to actual time travel
especially on the scale we see terraco
do even transporting multiple beings
from a completely different realm of
existence to aid him and his friends
aside from being a very convenient plot
device which
let's be fair it is these abilities
don't seem to come
out of nowhere and as you will soon come
to find out there is a far
deeper meaning to his existence so in
this video let's explore the enigma
that is terrico
let's start at the very beginning
terrico was built by zelda when she was
only a young child of six years old
assembled and refurbished from various
ancient parts which in and of itself
is already a cool piece of lore it shows
that the people of hyrule already knew
about the existence of the ancient shika
relics before
ganon's return was prophesized and the
massive excavation started and we're
digging up these relics from the past
as a hobby or curiosity while speaking
to her father
zelda reveals that she and her mother
were among those
interested in these relics and routinely
went out exploring together
she then hands him a small disc shaped
object they found on one of their
ventures which
later turns out to be an ancient shield
she also remarks that she and her mother
discussed it at some length and the two
surmised that it may hold hidden powers
this affirms that zelda without a doubt
inherited her interest for science and
technology from the queen who seems to
have been equally invested in the
ancient chica attack
it's no surprise then that even though
terraco was assembled by zelda her
mother is the prime candidate when it
comes to the actual programming
don't get me wrong i don't doubt that
zelda is a smart and capable person
but she is only six years old at this
point there are several aspects about
tarako that at least in my opinion
proves beyond a reasonable doubt that he
was programmed by the queen
the first one being that tarako is able
to do this
any veteran zelda player will
immediately know what this
is but if you haven't played any zelda
games prior to breath of the wild
this is zelda's lullaby it's a song that
made its debut as a story element in
ocarina of time which takes place
tens of thousands of years before the
events of breath of the wild and age of
calamity
and even in that game the song is
already described as ancient
so you can imagine how old this song
actually is
according to impa who teaches you the
song the melody is passed down by the
royal family and its notes hold
mysterious powers
the song didn't play a role in breath of
the wild however the song's notes
are found inside the sanctum decorated
around the rim of the giant crest of the
triforce
meaning that the knowledge about the
song does exist in this era but it's
safe to assume that nobody
except zelda's mother actually knew the
song and the power it holds since it's a
song that is mostly kept within the
royal bloodline
in ocarina of time impa was zelda's
personal protector
aka her guardian and was taught the song
by the royal family
most likely the queen of that era so it
makes sense that zelda's mother would be
the one to program the song into the
machine
tereko has shown to be extremely
protective of zelda
literally and figuratively acting as her
guardian
another big giveaway that tereco was the
queen's handiwork is the fact that he
reacts or activates upon the release of
zelda's divine power
if the queen did indeed possess this
power as well something that's becoming
more and more likely
only she would know how to program a
machine to read this type of energy
since she would be able to conjure up
this energy as well so
yeah i cannot think of anyone else that
could have programmed tarako with these
features
especially since the sheikah have been
banned from using the technology up
until the prophecy
the queen created the diminutive
guardian too well
literally be her guardian as well as a
companion of sorts
being a daughter of royalty she probably
didn't have a lot of friends growing up
attending normal schools is out of the
question for a child of her stature
even in real life traditionally royal
children were educated privately by
tutors
in this case her biggest tutor being the
queen herself
while her father busied himself with
ruling over the kingdom
zelda and her mother maintained a very
close bond
in part due to their shared interest in
technology and ancient relics
but the creation of terraco goes a lot
deeper than just being a companion
and protector for zelda and the
abilities the guardian possesses such as
being a jukebox for zelda's lullaby
reading the sacred divine power and of
course time travel
can all be explained if we look at the
bigger picture and in particular the
fact that the queen
may have been harboring a dark secret
around the same time that the prophecy
of ganon's inevitable return came to
light
another very significant event took
place the queen of hyrule passes away
unexpectedly leaving zelda without a
mother and
without a mentor now i'm not going to
get into the reason why
or how she died as that is still even
with age of calamity's backstory
unclear at this point instead i want to
suggest something that might be even
more
important to the overall arc of zelda
and her mother and that is that the
queen
may have foreseen her own death those
who possess the blood of the goddess and
thus harness her divine power
are in some occasions shown to have the
ability to see into
the future in ocarina of time for
instance zelda has visions
which literally predict the rise of
ganondorf before
it actually happens it's not too
far-fetched then that the queen
also possessed some degree of foresight
as well some speculate that she may have
even been the one who predicted the
return of calamity gannon
however there is also evidence that
contradicts this idea
either way for the theory at hand it
doesn't really matter if she did or not
what matters is that the queen may have
had premonitions of hyrule's impending
doom
and that she herself was not gonna be
around for much longer to do anything
about it
having unlocked her sacred power herself
she must have realized the risk that her
daughter
still being so young might not be able
to awaken her power in time to save
herself
her kingdom and her friends from ganon's
wrath especially with no one around to
teach her how
and well she was totally right zelda did
eventually manage to awaken her power
but by then
the damage had already been done hyrule
was devastated absolutely by calamity
ganon
in an attempt to change the outcome of
the future and give her kingdom a second
fighting chance
zelda's mother programmed and outfitted
terraco with all the tools needed to
make
this happen she knew that zelda would
eventually awaken her power but not
if this would happen in time thus she
makes sure that the guardian
automatically boots up and responds to
the presence of this divine power
something that would be easy for her to
do since she too
can generate this energy at will she
then modifies terracote to hold the
ability to time travel in case the
events don't play out as intended and
ganon succeeds
as a final measure she programmed
zelda's lullaby into the guardian
if he indeed would have to travel back
in time there is the risk that zelda
from the past
may not remember her companion and as we
saw in age of calamity
this is exactly the case shortly after
the queen's death and the prophecy of
ganon's return
her father thinking it was just a mere
toy and a distraction for his daughter
confiscates terrico so zelda can focus
on the mission ahead
that mission being unlocking her sacred
powers
being only six years old when this
occurs zelda slowly forgets about the
existence of her little companion while
growing up
and this is where the lullaby comes into
play it's quite poetic that a lullaby
which is a song described as a quiet
gentle melody sung to send a child to
sleep
is now used to awaken zelda's memories
from her childhood
we hear the guardian play it a total of
five times throughout age of calamity's
story
three times in the past and two times
during her memories
on two different occasions when the song
is played in the present
it manages to jog zelda's memory about
tarako her mother
and everything she suppressed since she
was a child and in all instances in the
present
it happens when she's in a state of
worry or sadness
it's obvious that the song was
programmed to comfort her but it also
seems to serve this secondary function
of helping her remember her past
there's only one instance in which it
doesn't accomplish this goal
which is when she breaks down in front
of the ravaged tyro castle right after
the calamity started likely because she
was too distracted with the fact that
she just saw her father getting murdered
or so she thinks and of course her
kingdom being on the verge of getting
torched because of her failings
instead this happens
now i know all right i know how cheesy
and cliche
this is having a tear activating some
sort of plot device to turn the tides
yeah i'm well aware of it but if we look
past the lazy storytelling here
even this could be explained in some way
if her mother could program terraco to
react to the divine power i
guess she could also do the same with a
tear of despair or sorrow from her
daughter
as cheap as that may be but as we know
this tier
causes the little guardian to once again
activate his time travel ability
but rather than jumping in time himself
he transports four key figures from
breath the wild's timeline
from a hundred years after he himself
jumped through time nonetheless
to age of calamity's timeline to help in
the fight against gannon how he's able
to do this
is beyond me and there's no real way to
explain what happens here without
severely stretching it
but i guess if the queen did have the
knowledge of foresight
she may have known that a hundred years
from now four individuals were going to
be born who would be a perfect fit to
aid them in this quest
i don't know like i said this is a
stretch and if you have your own ideas
about it feel free to share them down in
the comments
anyway with all these measures in place
zelda's mother assured that tarako's
presence would greatly improve the odds
for the kingdom and that is without
taking into account that he's also able
to activate shika towers and other
important technology which
also made a huge difference on the
outcome and may or may not have been
planned by the queen as well
which brings us to tarico as a character
it's clear that despite his programming
the guardian has a distinct personality
of his own
he's very playful bold and interruptive
especially towards impa
and even a bit passive aggressive on
some occasions like when he gets angry
at link for ruining his opportunity to
save zelda himself he even seems a bit
jealous of link and zelda's relationship
at times
though for reasons i will mention later
i don't think this has any romantic
motivations on the side of the guardian
but it's clear that tereko also
performed certain actions without being
conscious about it which makes sense
since if it's something pre-programmed
into him by zelda's mother
he himself wouldn't know why he's doing
it he's simply
executing a protocol i think this is
most evident from the scene we talked
about earlier
after getting hit by zelda's tear and
doing his little time shenanigans we can
clearly see that he is just as confused
as everyone else about what just
happened
almost as if shrugging his shoulders and
being like hey guys
i don't know either when he's just
hanging around the group he is acting
upon his
own personality however when he executes
one of these protocols
that is in a sense zelda's mother
forcing him to do whatever is needed
that includes opening the portal and
jumping back in time at the very
beginning of the game
so to paint a broader picture tarako
sits dormant on a shelf for 11 years
detects the presence of the divine power
and activates itself
as mentioned before zelda's mother knew
that zelda would eventually awaken her
power but wasn't sure if this was going
to be in time to save the kingdom
this means that tereco was programmed to
deal with two different scenarios in
breath of the wild's timeline
had zelda awakened her power in time the
war against ganon could have been won
she would have sealed ganon successfully
as was the original plan
or she would have been too late and the
kingdom would already be destroyed along
with everyone in it
tereko would have awakened either way
since in both scenarios the divine power
is
activated at some point the guardian
would then assess the situation
if hyrul has been saved he basically
doesn't have to do anything
however as we all know this is not how
things panned out
instead he wakes up sees the kingdom in
ruin and executes the time travel
protocol
jumps into the portal and the events of
age of calamity pick up
but we're not done yet there's one final
thing we need to address before rounding
up this theory
since if we're talking about terrico we
of course also have to mention his
doppelganger
harbinger ganon
despite this brilliant plan set up by
zelda's mother ganon had a plan of his
own and took swift countermeasures
since terrico jumped into the past this
of course means that in this new reality
there are now two terracotes one from
the present and the age of calamity
timeline
and one from the future aka breath of
the wild's timeline
the moment tariko jumps into the time
portal the demon king catapults slivers
of his malice into the portal right on
the heels
of the guardian turns out that this
malice ultimately landed on the terraco
from the present
this version of the tiny guardian is
literally possessed by ganon from breath
of the wild's timeline and because that
cannon is from the future
it in turn knows the future and is given
the name
harbinger gannon harbinger then
approaches astor to act as his mediator
and his puppet to impose his will and
strategies
this is why ganon is even more powerful
in age of calamity than he was in breath
of the wild
the knowledge of the future through
terraco didn't just benefit the heroes
of the story but also
their adversary it wasn't enough for
ganon to succeed in one timeline
and wanted to assure that hyrule met its
downfall in every branch of reality
if you finish the game which let's be
honest you probably have if you're
watching this video you already know how
the story concludes so i'm not going to
explain it in any finer detail
but what i will touch upon is that even
though this is by no means the most
original premise i do find it very
poetic how the duality between these two
guardians
is the very backbone of the story
because when you really think about it
if terico was indeed programmed by
zelda's mother
a being who possessed the power of the
goddess hylia and harbinger gannon is
well ganon that means that in a sense
this is a battle between the demon king
and goddess hylia
represented by the queen of hyrule not
in the literal sense of course
since it is still just a machine but a
machine that was quite literally
designed to do
what zelda's mother couldn't do in her
absence you could even draw a parallel
between this game
and terminator 2. if you've ever seen
that movie the premise of age of
calamity
may feel very familiar to you in this
story the world has been destroyed in a
cataclysmic event by skynet
a computer program which achieved
consciousness and deemed all humans to
be a threat to the planet
and its own existence only a small
sliver of humans still remains
which under the leadership of john
connor manages to persevere into
fighting back against the machines
as a way to deal with this last
resistance skynet sends a terminator
a machine designed to look human back in
time in an attempt to kill conor when
he's still a young boy
as a counter-measure the resistance
leader sends his own terminator which he
reprogrammed to protect his younger self
at all costs
so we have two machines from the future
one set to destroy and the other
to protect of course in age of
calamity's case it's zelda's mother who
programmed it and not
zelda herself but you gotta admit that
there are some very strong similarities
here
during the climax of age of calamity our
heroes are
somehow unable to hurt ganon despite the
master sword and even the sacred power
it's still not enough to win the fight
but we again
see terraco reawaken and reacting to the
divine power
and again it does what it was programmed
to do protects zelda and her kingdom at
all cost
heavily damaged and with all other
options exhausted
it makes a final sacrifice to help
destroy the evil that has plagued hyrule
for millennia
with this sacrifice ganon is now
rendered
vulnerable another testament that this
really was the queen of hyrule's doing
since
who else than zelda's mother could
actually hurt ganon
even after the master sword failed if
there wasn't some essence of her power
left in this little machine
in the final memory of zelda we see that
on the night of the queen's death
she gazes at a shooting star up in the
sky
she then calls out to her mother and
almost immediately
tarako starts playing zelda's lullaby
though she has passed
zelda's mother was never truly gone an
essence of her
lived on within zelda's companion all
throughout the story events of age of
calamity we see this reflected back on
tarako's behavior
being suspective of link when it
observes the chemistry between him and
zelda
as any mother would in a situation like
that this isn't jealousy
it's trying to protect her from possible
heartbreak but as link proves his
worthiness and his devotion
the guardian slowly accepts him
basically deeming him worthy of her
affection
we can even see it boldly trying to talk
sense into zelda's father
almost as if the queen herself is
indirectly trying to tell her husband to
go easy on their daughter
and be less strict with her of course
the king unable to understand what it
says
simply stares back at it in confusion
though we didn't get to see much of
zelda's mother in the flesh
there's a case to be made that in a
sense she was actually one of
if not the most important character in
the story
of age of calamity
if you want to see more about the queen
of hyrule and her history
please be sure to check out the video
made by commonwealth realm which is
basically a sister video to this one
the link will be in the description and
in the end card so
go check it out it's good thank you all
for watching and
have a great day
you